uh Hey guys welcome back to the TMG
podcast uh this is actually last week's
episode
if you want today's Epic
[Laughter]
ciao
[Applause]
what the [__]
[Laughter]
I'm back I'm back
what is this well I got so inspired when
I was in Europe
that uh you know I had so much [__]
mobile coffee that I figured why not
bring one back
noelle's Cafe
yeah are you mic'd up right now Noel's
Cafe menu cheeky espresso British tea
latte lemonade cigarette fish and chips
I'll do the cigarette you do the
cigarette yeah awesome dude well you
know it's yours it's European so you
know
I wanted to join you green these are
sick oh yeah
what are these
um Ultra Menthol okay sick you wanna you
wanna light up sure yeah
foreign
I'll get a coffee
he's already said that I think
is this how they do it in Italy
oh yeah that's European service
this is European business
okay yeah we're working on it okay
it's the first day of business
it's a little I'm a little confused here
hold that for me let's go okay cool
is this real
I don't understand are the hoses like
did you make this
dude this is my new business
how long have you been working on this
for like this is my new business this is
a full-on espresso machine
yeah
I invested in it I know
how's business going [__] clearly
awesome
you want a single or a double
um I'll do um I'll do a double and then
you can steam me some milk too
make a little latte
dude this is my sit down this is my
business I want to like look at it
just don't look too hard okay if you got
an A rating yeah that's incredible yeah
I know congrats thank you yeah first day
yeah you've already had like the food
board or whatever coming oh dude we're
good here we're good this is amazing
yeah man Europe's changed me
um
okay now look at that now if I can just
say that's a creamy [__] espresso
yeah that's awesome yeah that's gonna
make you come uh we got some oat milk
we forgot the tin can you know what I'll
just do yeah he's gonna go straight I
don't eat oat milk oh that's fair
did we put ham and I don't drink it we
put ham in that yeah we did yeah yeah we
did yeah this is incredible actually
yeah no yeah we we um we killed that pig
this morning as I said the uh the
croissant's amazing thank you looking
forward to this have a sip of that uh
let me take Grazie yeah
and uh
yeah yeah yeah
grazia yeah
and um
what's the Prego Prego Prego
um yeah thank you yeah
all right I'm gonna get up on out of
here okay all right so joining us for
the episode today or yeah I guess but I
got you got other customers to tend to I
gotta get over to a downtown LA
oh
are you gonna ride that uh-huh yeah I
gotta yeah you better get gone yeah I
gotta get to the you know parking lot uh
food truck Extravaganza yeah yeah you
know they got some bigger trucks there
so it's gonna be a competition but are
you gonna take the 10 or uh if if I can
get on it if I can get up the ramp I'll
definitely
I'll be there so funny you on the 10.
Prego
whatever you're saying what were you
saying when you came in here
um
get the [__] out of the way
[Laughter]
isn't that Spanish yeah dude I'm all
over okay yeah so you think I [__]
learned these catchphrases just hanging
out in America
you made me drop my cigarette
so yeah I was gonna do the rest of the
episode like this I'm just gonna lean on
my
yeah
I'm gonna yeah this is horrible yeah
cause there's no sugar in it you [__]
bad American this is really bad you're
just so addicted to Sugar you never had
real taste before yeah do you have any
do you have any cinnamon
um I've been putting cinnamon vanilla
coffee mate in my coffee every morning
oh do we have a [__] half a Snickers
bar we can put into this I literally I
wanted to get one of these a bike a
virtue cycle oh for what to start a
competing Coffee Card
leave it to Cody his competitive
business nature we're both gonna like
take up different sides of the parking
lot
what do you mean parking lot the space
parking lot yeah
that's that is what I learned in Europe
man it's I commend anyone who can
maintain thickness in Europe
because uh they that's the one thing we
have have down in America
speed and customer service
oh yeah
what do you mean romantic
uh you know people in Europe I've I've
deduced why they're so skinny or why
they're thinner
they won't take forever they everything
takes forever they walk everywhere and
they're always drinking coffee and
smoking cigarettes it's just they're
just not eating they're just suppressing
appetite yeah all day
and then they're getting 40 000 steps a
day dude Lisbon you want to get sexy
go to Lisbon for a month you like
listening
yes
I actually like Lisbon on my chin
yeah who's Liz because
yep
go ahead no I'm just I'm just saying
this kind of an own to her yeah yeah
it's true Lisbon's you know yeah Lisbon
my nuts or something like that and like
what's been sitting on my face yeah Liz
been pissing in my face yeah uh Lisbon
you know I don't know you want to sit
down eventually
my neck hurts
that's okay
I kind of like this view from the back
ew that's the European way dude okay you
know I spent 24 hours in Berlin I'm a
changed man
you know you know what to do with
himself you don't know talk or eat it's
your favorite thing
Tom was amazing thanks man yeah we made
it
we made it here
that was one of the best ham and cheese
croissants I've ever had
yeah bro
just wait till I get the ice cream truck
in here
we should we should just keep
introducing new businesses yeah
yeah I'm all you know because that's the
thing bro
I'm always
I'm always cooking up new ideas
one of the ones that [__] one of the
weeks
I was gonna say one of the weeks you
know we should get crazier and crazier
with the carts that we're starting oh
yeah and then one of them is like um
you know it's like a
in-cell experience cart yeah and we
wheel it in it's just an apple Vision
headset yeah and just a just a dark room
and a flashlight yeah well it's funny
you say that you've got your Apple
Vision on right now
oh wow Ryan gets a microphone and all of
a sudden he's funny